at mike morrell does miami now have the
draft capital to acquire russell wilson
and would they include tua
in the trade interesting point and yeah
look at what the dolphins have but i
don't know why you do 12
to 6
unless you're just trying to make that
as enticing as possible when you offer
six
plus to a plus more to the seattle
seahawks for russell wilson look today's
moves tell us you can never rule out
anything and you never know what's going
to happen so
they do have the ammunition to make it
work if they want to miles uh
the question is whether or not they want
to try and whether or not the seahawks
listen
i'm so glad that this question got asked
because i was thinking about this as i
made my roast beef sandwich for lunch
today not quite at 12 noon as you know
you eat your lunch then like but it's
got to be exactly 12 o'clock yeah yeah
but you know what i i i think that at
least you got to pick up the phone if
you're miami why not why not at least
see
if there's something that could maybe
entice uh the seattle seahawks in order
to want to move russell wilson and now
that also would have to be enticing for
russell wilson because he's got that no
trade clause and the miami dolphins were
not on that list of four teams that his
agent put out there publicly so i i
think it's worth exploring if you're the
miami dolphins why not at least explore
it it doesn't mean you have to do it but
i would explore it certainly
a similar question from heart cation do
you think if desean watson gets through
his legal issues miami will set up a
huge trade package to get him
there's a lot of hurdles that would need
to be cleared and i think that deshaun
watson already is looking at an unpaid
suspension even if he would resolve all
of these cases to the satisfaction of
everyone involved and more than 90 of
all civil claims get resolved before
they end up at trial so there are ways
to work these out where everyone is
pleased with the outcome but even if you
do that you've got to worry about the
league office the draft is going to come
and go i just think it's too many pieces
to have come together in the next five
weeks so i don't see deshawn watson
being traded to miami before the draft
now they've got future pieces but why
would you when you have the 12th pick
why would you give up
a first round pick next year if you're
thinking maybe next year
we get him or maybe after the draft we
get him with one of those first round
picks next year why would you give that
up so i feel like they're planning to go
forward with what they have at least for
a year and with the sean watson stuff
there's too much smoke there there's too
much uncertainty to have a plan that you
would have any real faith in miles
yeah and that's why i think the rus if
you wanted to maybe trade for russell
wilson a it would probably take a little
bit less to get russell wilson because
he's older than deshawn watson and so
that's one element of it and then also i
think what you're saying is true just
the indication of giving up that first
round pick from next season to then get
back up to six it really does seem to
say that they want to go with tuataga
viloa in 2021 see what they have at the
very least and then maybe you know year
three as we were just saying about
daniel jones and sam darnold that
becomes the key year for two attack of
iloa but i think that the jury is still
out on him and it doesn't necessarily
mean that you can't trade you know for
somebody who you perceive to be a great
quarterback already especially when it
comes to desean watson i just think that
there's too many issues right now that
won't be resolved before the draft as
you were just saying mike and it
wouldn't necessarily make sense to do
that
one more real quickly at jet fan lucifer
what does it take for carolina to move
to the number two pick look the number
two pick is zach wilson you're not
trading for the second pick you're
trading for zach wilson and if the jets
have decided that's who they want
and they've decided to move on from sam
darnold you're almost in a desean watson
russell wilson situation where
they're locked in on their franchise
player
that they want
i don't know what it's going to take to
get their attention because if you drop
the number eight you're not getting your
quarterback period and you may not have
any quarterback by the time you get the
number eight miles um so i think that
they should just forget about trying to
move to number two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports